كحال غالبيه مستشفيات الصين يغص هذا
المستشفى في شنغهاي بالمصابين بكوفيت 19
مرضى من كافه الاعمار يشغلون الغرف
والممرات على السواء انفجار في اعداد
الاصابات تشهده البلاد بعد تخليها عن
سياسه صفر كوفيد تحت ضغط احتجاجات شعبيه
ضد الاغلاقات والقيود الصحيه لكن هذا
التغيير في نهج الحكومه فجاه النظام الصحي
في البلاد
الاسبوع الماضي
يوميا بعد ان كنا نستقبلوا سبعه او ثمانيه
فقط
تبدو فارغه بسبب الانتشار الكبير لمتحول
جديد للفيروس حتى ان السلطات الصحيه تقول
انها سجلت سبعه وثلاثين مليون اصابه في
يوم واحد ارقام تثير قلق العالم
الاجسام المضاده وايضا هل هو متحور اكثر
قابليه
منظمه الصحه العالميه اي بيانات من الصين
حول الحالات الجديده منذ ان علقت بكين
العمل بسياسه صفر كوميدي وترى المنظمه
الدوليه ان ذلك قد يكون بسبب الصعوبات
التي تواجهها بالدين في احصاء الحالات